僕はですねあの北海道の千歳市っていう
場所出身で
新千歳空港から10分ぐらいの場所が実家
になってますけど
名字は成り立っていますのでよろしくお
願いしますありがとうございます
優しいなで
えっとまあ千歳のですね非常にこう山奥に
座っていて千歳市民からも馬鹿にされる
ぐらいあの田舎町でですねあの
近所の人たちは全員友達っていうような
感じになっていて
全員下の名前で呼び合うような関係性の街
に暮らしてましたなので
中学校高校と過ごしていってですね
絶対にこう出てやると
広い世界を見てや
るっていうところがすごいこう自分の中で
のモチベーションになっていてこの
映画というか小説をご
存知の方いらっしゃるかいらっしゃらない
かなんですけどもあの僕のその
原体験としては非常に大きなところを占め
ているものになります
在日韓国人の
映画になっていましてその中で葛藤し
ながらアイデンティティを模索していくっ
ていうような
物語なんですけどその中でですねあの広い
世界を見るのだと
差別したりとかあの知らないっていうこと
が持つことってそもそものそのための知識
がないから
差別してるんだっていうことで彼は
ものすごい勉強するんですよね日本で
生まれて日本で育ってるのになぜか在日
だった差別されるような自分の人生に対し
て
こん畜生と
勉強してやるっていうことですねあの勉強
して勉強して
自分のアイデンティティを獲得していくっ
ていうような物語でそれをすごいこう
影響が受けましてですね
僕は千歳のどや中になんですけど
山奥にいてもですねあの
勉強はできるんですよあの
素晴らしいですよね義務教育ってあので
勉強していってあの様々なことを学んで
いくことによって
自分の
世界を広げていくということにすごい
モチベーションを感じていたので
様々なことを勉強して絶対東京行きたいな
と思って東京の大学を受けて
二郎したんですけどもなんとかこう
入り込んだというようなことですね
東京行った東京行ったで
[音楽]
ある大学に入ったんですけどそこでの
過ごし方っていうのはみんななんか東京
生まれ東京とかで自分の親父も全員
中高一貫校だったりとかっていうような
学校だったのでなんか違うなと思っていて
でさらにもっと広い世界が見たいなという
ことで
プーさんを背負いながらですねずっと大学
時代はバイクに乗って
ガソリンスタンドでバイトしたりとか
渋谷のバーで働いたりとかしながらですね
様々な人によって
自分の世界をこう拡張するっていうことに
ものすごいモチベーションを感じていまし
たそういうこともあってですねあの就職先
は
グローバルに活動している会社に入ろうっ
ていうことでですね
車会社に入ってですね
仕事をしていましたここで6年間仕事した
のち
ブラジルに駐在をさせていただきましたで
ブラジルで日本から考えたらその地球の
反対側にあるので
本当にそんな場所に人がいるのかなって
いうのがまああの
何でしょうね好奇心もあったので本当に
どんどん広い世界広い世界と行きたくて
結局地球の反対側に生かしていただいたん
ですけどもそこにもやっぱり人がいてあの
生活を営んでるんですけどそういう人生を
やっていったんですけどでもずっと
サラリーマンやってたので
広い分広く広くあの世界を言ったんです
けどその分なんか浅かったなって思う自分
がいてその時になんかこのまんまじゃ自分
はまずいんじゃないかということで30歳
の時にですね
Amazon川で
ターン常備を迎えてピラニア食いながら
ですね
俺はこのままじゃいけないって思ってです
ね何なんだろう自分はっていうことですね
自分は何のためにこんなに広い世界を見て
いたんだろうと言ったところで
次は広くじゃなくて
狭くてもいいから深く行こうということに
決めて
ブラジルからですねあの上司に電話をかけ
ていきなり
会社を辞めますと
言ってみれば自分はあのある程度この出世
コースみたいなのっていたんですけども
それを全部こう突き放しですねやめますっ
て言ったからもう本社の方は大激震が起き
てですね何を言ってるんだお前は
ふざけんなお前が何ができるんだみたいな
こと言われたんですけどもその時にあの
まさにですねあの
住所を否定無職の状態で日本に戻ってきて
これから何を成し遂げようどうしようって
思っていてだけど自分であの
事業を作って
起業して
世界を変えるんだという時に
様々な人たちにお会いさせていただきまし
た
住所
無職っていう期間にですねあの半年間
ぐらいあったんですけどその時にあの
1000人ぐらいの人にいろんな全国各地
の人たちにお会いしに行って
自分はこういう人間なんですと
自分はだけど何がしたいか
わからないんですと
そういうこと言われていると聞く聞いてる
方は
頑張ってねぐらいで終わっちゃうんです
けどそれがすごい悔しかったし
自分として何ができるのかということを
試したいけども何がしたいのかわからない
良い大学入って言い会社入ったけども
結局何者でもない」っていうのに直面して
まあ非常にこう苦しんでですねあのこの時
のその本もBの方がきっていう本なんです
けども
皆さんもその
Doの方がまあやってることとか自分の
所属してる組織の名前はあるけどあなたは
何者なんですか成田智也は何者なんです
かって言われた時に
答えられない自分に対してすごい葛藤して
いる期間が結構長かったと思いますです
けど
様々な人にお会いするのにつれてですね
自分の世界は広く広くと言ってる割に
浅かったしなんか狭かっただけどあの逆に
自分が持ってるものもそれ色々あるんだ
なっていうことはあの気づいていきました
あのいろんな人たちにない場合ほどですね
あでも成田君ってこういういいところが
あるよねとかこういう
経歴を持ってるっていうのは新しいねと
かっていうことをまあそういうことブラジ
ルっていうこととかも含めてですねあった
のでそういうことを自分の中でこうあの
咀嚼しながらですね
自分の価値観っていうのを磨いていきまし
てでそんな時にですねあのどこで会社を
作ろうとか何をしようと思った時に
北海道の胆振東部地震がありましたで
2018年の9月6日にまだ僕はブラジル
にいたんですけど
自分の生まれ故郷千歳市の隣町がですね
あの大きく被災していて
多くの方が亡くなっているだけど
前向いて頑張ろうとしている
厚真町の方々と出会いがありましてですね
まあその中で何ができるかなと何ができる
かわからないけど何かしたいという時に
ビジネスが
社会課題を解決して人の笑顔を作ってお金
をいただくということをやるならば
多分なるブルシットジョブをやってるん
じゃなくて
価値あることを提供するならば
東京で起業するよりも
厚真町とか
各地のその課題を抱えある場所とへ戦うっ
てことは価値があるんじゃないかなと思っ
て今は妻町で
会社を作ってますでまぁ何者でもない自分
がエンジニアでもないしプログラマーでも
なかったんですけども
自分の特技がいろいろあるなっていう
ところは
気づいていって
自分はですね今世の中っていうのはかなり
分断していることが多いと思ってるんです
けども
例えばその都会と
地域とか大
企業と
ベンチャーとか
ベテラン高齢者ですね
ベテランの方々と
若者の価値観だったりとか
デジタルとアナログとか
民間と行政だったりとかそういうこう様々
な分断している物事を
僕はこう飛び回ってですね
教会を超えてかき混ぜることができるん
だろうなっていうことでなんか教会を超え
て世界をかき混ぜるというコンセプトの
マドラー株式会社っていうことで
僕の
愛犬ですねゴールデンレトリーバーのサラ
ちゃんをですねあのモチーフにしながら
尻尾で世界をかき混ぜるぞっていうことを
ちょっとやるって知ってもらってます
であのまあ様々な物事っていうのは一見
こう
絶対に見えているけども
実は相対的であるってことが僕の中で
すごいこうテーマとして持っていてあの
何事もですね一番大きなことは例えば国
ですね
国っていうのは
実はものすごいこうファジーなものなん
ですけどそれを日本っていうのは
当たるものだとか
イギリスっていうものだっていうふうに
やっているっていうのがすごいこう気に
なっていて
自分のその実はその大学時代の専門が歴史
なんですよねで歴史の中でこれすごい名著
なんで読んでいただければいいんですけど
も
想像の共同体っていうことで今
言っている国っていう概念ができたなって
19世紀の末でしてそれより前っていうの
はもっと別の存在としてあったんですけど
今っていうのはものすごいその
ルールブックの上で非常にかっこ食べ物と
していってるんですけどものすごい実は
ファジーなものなんだよと
わかりやすいのはイギリスなんですよね
イギリスっていう国なんてどこにもなくて
あるのって
グレートブリテン及び北部アイランド連合
王国っていう形でですねアイルランド
しかもアイルランドで北だけなんですよね
ものすごいそれもですねあのいろんな
アクティビティがあってそうなってるん
ですけどそうした時にどこで何が絶対で
あるのかっていうのって時代とともに変化
してるんですけどその一瞬の生きたその人
たちからするとそれが確固たるものだと
いうところで
強く持とうとするんですけど
実はそもそも
歴史上はかなり相対なんだよってことに
なんか気づいてほしいなっていうことも
ありまして
物事っていうのは様々なものでラベリング
とかレッテルを貼りますあのハルと楽なん
ですあの人はこういう人だよねとかこう
いう人はそういうことするよねとかって
いうことでウハとか
左派とか
保守とかなんか様々な言葉ありますけど
でそういうことを考えていた時にあの
例えば人と出会った時ってその人に対して
あの
ラベリングしてきますこの人は
男性で
何歳で何が好きでこういう服装してるから
こうでみたいな感じになっていくんです
けど例えば僕だったらその何でしょうね
黒い服着てて
男で
シスジェンダーで言うと僕は
シスなんですけどっていうことだったりだ
とか
女性のことが好きでとか
蟹座で
ab型で日本人ab型血液型占い大好き
ですよねで
何々でみたいな感じになっていってでも
それってすごいこう
傲慢というか
勝手にま自分が理解しやすいからそうする
んですけどでも物事ってそもそものその
ラベリングのレッテルのその1ワード時代
はものすごいこうファジーだということに
なって日本人だからこう韓国人だからこう
中国人だからこうっていうのは本当に一
部分でしかないというのでそれをこう破壊
していうようなことをやっていきたいなと
いうふうに思っていますなのでもう
ものすごい今世の中っていうのはブーカな
時代になっているっていうよく言います
けど
むしろ今までがわかりやすすぎた
戦後は復興してこう
頑張るんだ大企業がいいんだ
都会がかっこいいんだみたいな感じで
簡単にラベリングして
レッテルを貼って理解をしてきたんです
けどそもそも
世の中っていうのは
すごいファジーで
すごい
わかりにくいものであ
るっていうことをなんか理解した上で
なんか物事を進めていきたくてなので僕ら
はその様々なこう高齢者だからとか
若者だからとか
都会だから地域だから大企業だから
ベンチャだから行政だから民間だから
みたいなことを
全部こうやってですねあの一旦
対立しているようなものをよく言う言葉で
言うとその伝承法っていう概念があるん
ですけどその弁証法の中で言うと
アウフヘーベン一見対立してるものを次の
次元に持っていこうっていうか
考え方なんですけど
えー例えばなんですけどねあの経済活動と
環境問題を両立するためにじゃあ車を作る
のをやめようとかいやもうあの
車を作りたいっていう人とエコーを推進し
たいという人だったらでもそれを乗り越え
てもしかしたらハイブリッドカーっていう
概念があったのかもしれないしあのEVと
いう概念があったのかもしれないしって
いうことで
様々な一見対立しているものを次の
次元に持っていくマドラーではそういう
こともやっていきたいなというふうに思っ
てますし一見一見ですよ本当に対立してる
わけでは全くないんですけどもそれをこう
どんどん乗り越えていくってことをやって
いきたいなってことで
過疎地って言われている場所4400人
しか人口がいませんって言いますし
目の前には93歳のお母さんが
いらっしゃるんですけどその93歳の
お母さんが
果たして
デジタルができないかっていうとそんな
ことも全くなくてですねあの昨日一昨日か
なぐらいには
なんかすごい素敵な
86歳のお母さんがですねあの僕カフェも
やってるんですけどそのカフェに
達世代の人たちが集まるような場所になっ
てるんですけどそこに来て
スマートウォッチの付け方を教えて欲し
いって言ってきたんですよねこれ結構
びっくりして
えもう
言い方ですけど86歳の方がそんな
スマートウォッチをまず持って
るってことです
買ってみたのっていうかやっぱりその簡単
に人を認めて判断してこの人はデジタルが
できないとかなんかそういう概念ではなく
てあのその部分も何でしょうね一緒にこう
繋がって
解決できるといいんじゃないかなっていう
ふうに思っていて
なのでそういうことでですね僕らはその今
北海道っていう拠点ないし厚真町という
拠点で
活動してますけどもその中に
様々なこの何でしょう一見異聞かみたいな
ものをどんどんこう混ぜてってそうすると
爆発が起きてですねあの次なる
シーンに行けるんじゃないかなっていう
ところで
様々な活動させていただいてましてその中
の一番コツというか大事にしなきゃいけ
ないことが
リスペクトだなと思っていますあの人
それぞれっていうのは先程ありましたけど
もそのダイヤル合わせていった時になんか
存在を認めるっていうよりはあのそもそも
全員違うしあの
同じ日本人とか何人とか
言っても全部違うんです同じ
学歴を持っていようと全員違うその
一人一人の違いっていうものを楽しみ
ながら
リスペクトしていくってことをやりきると
あのその
難しいんですけどねそれをそのまま
受け入れるって非常に困難もっと簡単に
ラベリングした方が超楽なんですけどでも
それをやめてこの人はそういう人生は歩ん
できたし様々なことを感じてきたんだなっ
ていうことをやっていくその時にもう本当
に大事な言葉が
リスペクトだなと思っていて
様々な人たち様々な概念様々な
事柄に対してのあのこういうことを持って
いきたいなと思っていてで人間っていうの
が非常に面白いなと思ってましてあの人間
って人じゃなくて人間って間って入
るっていうのが
面白いなと思っていて間が入る以上は2個
あるんですよね2個以上ないと間って
生まれないじゃないですかもうそうすると
2つ以上があるから社会が生まれて2人
以上いて3人4人となってから間が
生まれるそのリレーションシップによって
様々な出会いが生まれてくっていうことだ
と思うんですけどそれを考えると先ほどの
その一人一人が全員そもそも違うっていう
ことになるならば
[音楽]
異文化交流とか異文化体験とかよく言って
みんなその海外とか旅行すると思うんです
けどそもそも今隣の席に座ってる方って
全く違う人生送ってきていて
全く違う価値観を持ってい
るってことになるならば
隣の人としっかり話し合うことを対話する
ことをこそがもうすでに文化交流だなと
思ってますし
わざわざどこか遠くに行くっていうよりは
あの
目の前の人をしっかりなんでしょうね
体の底から話し合うみたいなことができ
るっていうのが
リスペクトをした上で
窓らしていくためには本当に必要なんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思ってますなので
[音楽]
僕らはですねそういう活動を今あの北海道
厚真町ないし北海道っていう単位で
様々なことやらせてもらってますけども
こういうことを踏まえてですねあの
世の中をどんどん広く見てきたつもりでし
たけど次は狭く深くいきながらそれが次
広くて
深い状態になったらものすごいもっと世界
っていうのが変えれるんじゃないかなと
これだけ解像度を持ちながら
目の前のことを何だろう見つめながら
次なるアクションに対するその
テクノロジーを持ってくるとかあの人と
つながりがもっと面白くなるとかってこと
を日々やりながらですねこのなんとかもう
この分断してる世の中に対して
世界平和を実現するためにですね僕は日々
戦っていければなというふうに思ってます
ということであのーかき混ぜながら
頑張っていこうと思いますので
皆さんと一緒に
楽しんでいければなというふうに思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]